>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Bien, buenas tardes,
a todos y a los colegas del
departamento de Español y Portugués
de la Universidad de
Maryland en College Park,
siempre es muy lindo
recibirlos aquí, así que --
, una vez más empezamos
una colaboración.
Hoy tenemos al profesor José María
Naharro presentando su libro,
aquí acompañado de grandes figuras
que harán una pequeña presentación y
luego tomarán parte en una
conversación con José María.
Pero los dejo con Eyda Merediz,
la directora del departamento
de español y portugués de la
Universidad de Maryland que
va a hacer una introducción de
nuestros invitados.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Eyda Merediz: Buenas tardes,
muchas gracias por estar aquí,
en esta tarde de una temperatura
tan agradable allá afuera,
pero es infinitamente
más agradable venir aquí,
a la Biblioteca del Congreso y ser
recibidos por la Hispanic Division
que siempre es nuestro aliado en
todo tipo de presentaciones y hoy
tenemos una.
Le quiero dar infinitas gracias a
Talia Guzman, que es la persona,
el contacto principal y
también a Georgette Dorn,
la Directora del Hispanic Division,
por continuar haciendo este tipo
de colaboraciones con nosotros,
por recibirnos, ¿no?, y por
además de permitirnos hacer esto,
sacar las joyas que tienen aquí en
su colección y al final si pueden
echarle un vistazo, por ejemplo,
a algunos de los afiches que
tenemos de la época y a fotos.
Le doy también las gracias
a la curadora, ¿no?, que,
colega que ha sacado de
la colección de arte esto.
También tenemos una colección de
libros que se va a presentar hoy,
pero otros, algunos incurables
que tiene la biblioteca.
Bienvenidos.
Y, efectivamente, como
ha dicho Talia,
hoy celebramos a José María Naharro,
nuestro colega de muchos años y
a su libro que acaba de salir.
Y tenemos de visita a dos
estudiosos, importantes,
uno que además hace mucha
ola en Facebook, [risas],
es amigo mío en Facebook y yo miro
todo lo que está pasando allí,
[risas].
Voy a presentarlos para que
sepan cuáles son sus logros,
voy hablar de los tres y de ahí les
voy a pedir a los dos presentadores
que vengan aquí al pódium y hagan
una presentación de aproximadamente
20 minutos, le pediremos al profesor
Naharro que responda o que dialogue
con las presentaciones y lo abrimos
a preguntas y podemos hablar de
cosas escabrosas, como por ejemplo,
lo que va a pasar el
primero de octubre, [risas].
>> José María Naharro-Calderón: ¿Tú
sabrás?, y lo [inaudible] [risas].
>> Eyda Merediz: El profesor José
María Naharro-Calderón es graduado
de la Universidad de Pensilvania
donde obtuvo su doctorado en 1985 y
es profesor de literatura española,
culturas ibéricas y estudios sobre
el exilio en la Universidad de
Maryland desde 1987.
¿No?, sus investigaciones cubren
tanto España como Latinoamérica,
especialmente los temas de
literatura del exilio y cine,
áreas en la que es reconocido
por su influyente trabajo.
Es autor de los libros "Entre
el exilio y el interior:
el entre siglo y Juan
Ramón Jiménez", de 1994;
y el que nos ocupa hoy,
"Entre alambradas y exilios.
Sangrías de las Españas
y terapias de Vichy".
Ha traducido: "Salvo en el
cumpleaños de la Reina Victoria:
Historias de las minas
de Río Tinto", 1985,
que fue reeditado en el 2010.
Y ha editado un número doble
de la Revista Anthropos
"Sobre Juan Ramón Jiménez
y Zenobia Camprubí", 1989.
Así como las actas de: "El exilio en
las Españas de 1939 en las Américas:
¿Adónde fue la canción?", de 1991,
y "Los exilios de las Españas de
1939 por sendas de la memoria",
de 1999; ambas conferencias llevadas
a cabo en la Universidad de Maryland
College Park.
También editó un volumen de la
poesía del poeta chileno Raúl
Barrientos, Jazz, en 1997; una
edición crítica de "Manuscrit,
Manuscrit Corbeau"
[fonético], ¿ah?,
"Manuscrito Cuervo" de
Max Aub, en el 98-99,
"Ochenta nuevos aforismos de Juan
Ramón Jiménez y dos números de
memorias" y "On Spanish
Republican memories
in France" en la Revista
Migraciones y Exilios,
del 2004 y 2005 -- 2014-2015.
Realizó las ediciones críticas de
"El rapto de Europa" en el 2008 y
"Campo francés", del
2008 también, de Max Aub.
Y "Poeta en la arena", del
2010; "El paraíso incendiado",
"La almohada de arena", "Versos del
marquis", del 2011, de Celso Amieva.
Ha publicado numerosos artículos
sobre Francisco Martínez la Rosa,
Pío Baroja, Benito Pérez Galdós,
César Vallejo, Luis Cernuda,
Francisco Villaespesa, Mercedes
Escolano, Jorge Guillén,
Jaime Gil de Biedma, Ana Rossetti,
Camilo José Cela, Antonio Machado,
Rafael Morales, Ana María Fagundo,
Paulino Masip, Leopoldo Lugones,
Enmanuel Velásquez -- Manuel Vázquez
Montalbán, María Luisa Elió o Elío,
la generación X, literatura
en Madrid, cine español,
la literatura de la
Guerra Civil Española,
el exilio español de
1939 y sus memorias.
Actualmente es el presidente de la
Asociación para el Estudio de las
Migraciones y Exilios
Ibéricos Contemporáneos,
y miembro del Consejo Editorial de
las Revistas Migraciones y Exilios,
Laberintos y Correo de Euclides.
Ese es el tipo de talento que
tenemos en la Universidad de
Maryland y en el departamento
de español y portugués.
OK? Ahora voy a presentar a
nuestros dos, este, invitados,
primero al Doctor Sebastián Faber,
¿lo pronuncio correctamente,
Faber?, o es --
>> Sebastián Faber: Sí, sí.
>> Eyda Merediz: OK.
Es profesor y jefe de -- lo
pregunto porque, porque es holandés.
Es profesor y jefe de Estudios
Hispánicos en Oberlin College en
Ohio, tiene un doctorandun
[fonético] equivalente a una
maestría de Literatura Española
de la Universidad de Ámsterdam,
y un doctorado en la Universidad
de California en Davis de 1999.
Además de ser el autor de numerosos
artículos y volúmenes coeditados
sobre temas que van desde la teoría
de la ideología a la Guerra Civil
Española, es autor de "Exile
and Cultural Hegemony:
Spanish Intellectuals in Mexico,
1939-1975", Vanderbilt, 2002.
O también de "Anglo-American
Hispanists
and the Spanish Civil War:
Hispanophilia, Commitment
and Discipline", Palgrave,
2008; y "Memory Battles
of the Spanish Civil War:
History, Fiction, Photography",
de Vanderbilt también,
de próxima publicación.
Creo que lo acabamos de anunciar,
así que tendremos libro pronto.
Sus áreas académicas de interés
incluyen estudios transatlánticos
ibero -- latinoamericanos, historia
institucional del hispanismo,
memoria histórica de la
España postfranquista,
cine español Luis Buñuel,
cine postfranquista,
literatura y exilio de
la Guerra Civil Española,
representaciones de la Guerra Civil
Española y refugiados de la Guerra
Civil, la que -- la crisis de
la vuelta al siglo en España e
Iberoamérica, intelectuales
y el compromiso político,
contactos e intelectuales entre
España e Iberoamérica, ¿eh?,
después del -- de 1810, construcción
de identidad hispánica luego de la
independencia de Latinoamérica,
teoría de la ideología,
ficción contemporánea española,
periodismo, ficción y Latinoamérica.
Entre el 2010 y 2015 fue jefe de la
Junta de Gobernadores del Abraham
Lincoln Brigade Archives (ALBA) y es
coeditor de la revista trimestral de
ALBA, the volunteer, ¿no?
Contribuye regularmente en los
medios de España y Estado Unidos
incluyendo Contexto, La Marea,
¿eh?, Frontera De, and The Nation.
Creo que es suficiente
sobre Sebastián Faber, pero,
es una estrella, [risas].
Tenemos otra, además, otra estrella,
Germán Labrador Méndez, ¿no?,
que es profesor asociado en el
departamento de Lenguas y Culturas
Españolas y Portuguesa de
la Universidad de Princeton,
desde el 2008.
Sus intereses incluyen la
historia cultural literaria,
los estudios de memoria, la poesía,
los movimientos sociales
y las culturas urbanas,
su área de investigación
principal es la España moderna
y contemporánea.
Antes de Princeton impartió clases
en la Universidad de Salamanca y en
la Universidad de Hamburgo.
Se doctoró por la Universidad
de Salamanca y codirigido por la
Soborna en Francia.
Es autor de "Letras arrebatadas:
Poesía y química en la transición
española" sobre un grupo de poetas
clandestinos españoles que
utilizaron la literatura drogada en
la simbolización de la
experiencia histórica.
Su segundo libro "Culpables
por la literatura:
Imaginación política y contracultura
en la transición española",
que acaba de aparecer
en la cal [fonético],
analiza los intentos de las
contraculturas españolas por superar
la democracia de baja
intensidad postfranquista,
a través de la biotecnología
y el activismo de los años 70.
Estos son temas que no se trataban
en Princeton cuando yo estudiaba
allí, [risas].
Muy bien. Actualmente, está
editando una antología de poetas
antifranquistas que se llama
"Muerto el perro se acabó la rabia:
25 poetas de la transición española"
y prepara una edición crítica del
libro "Los muertos" de
José, de José Luis Hidalgo,
una colección de poemas editados
durante la dictadura que denuncia la
existencia de fosas
comunes del franquismo.
Sus investigaciones en curso
incluyen dos proyectos de libros.
La primera es la producción cultural
de la crisis en la España de hoy,
dedicado a la cultura popular,
la resistencia y la política.
Mientras que la segunda es
un estudio sobre la política
conmemorativa del estado durante la
restauración y el nacimiento de la
segunda república en relación
con la desobediencia política.
Con eso terminamos la
presentación de nuestros, este --
participantes y llamo al
profesor Faber para que inicie
su intervención.
Gracias otra vez por estar aquí.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Sebastián Faber:
Muchísimas gracias.
¿Se me escucha bien?
¿Le parece bien que
le hable en castellano?
[ Silencio ]
Ah, muchas gracias, es un
honor y un placer estar aquí,
nunca había estado en
esta gran biblioteca,
aunque siempre había soñado con
los objetos que hay, entonces,
espero al menos sentarme con uno
secretamente y llevármelo a casa,
[risas], ¿no?, [risas].
Pues voy a sacar fotos
entonces, [inaudible] con eso.
Éste es un gran placer,
hablar aquí,
estar aquí para hablar de este
maravilloso e indispensable libro de
Chema Naharro, llevamos
muchos años esperándolo, y, y,
realmente es muy importante
que esté aquí.
No sólo es un libro importante e
indispensable sino que creo que
tiene tres rasgos de
escritorios más, es un libro,
es un libro difícil, es un libro
disidente y es un libro desbordante.
Y lo que, en el tiempo
que tengo aquí,
los 20 minutos voy a intentar
explicar que quiero decir con estos
tres adjetivos y porqué
creo que un libro disidente,
desbordante y difícil es
un libro exílico, entonces,
es un texto que trata
del exilio, obviamente,
pero también es un texto
escrito desde el exilio.
Cierro mi intervención con una
reflexión sobre qué significa esto
de ser un texto exílico, y hasta qué
punto nos invita a pensar un poco
sobre el significado de los
que trabajamos en España,
sobre España y desde
fuera de España.
Creo que ser un texto exílico nace
en parte de lugar de enunciación o
donde se escribe físicamente tanto
como [inaudible] y creo que, ah,
es obvio que este texto como diré
al final también un poco más con
[inaudible] es un texto escrito
desde una conciencia española
desplazada desde hace mucho tiempo
que es una conciencia descolocada en
el buen sentido de la
palabra Chema, digo, ¿no?,
que busca también descolocar
a sus lectores y sus lectoras.
Contagiarlas un poco del virus
o quizás vacunarlas con el virus
exílico, de la visión desde fuera.
He dicho que "Entre
alambradas" es un libro difícil,
para empezar lo es
a nivel de estilo,
no tiene sentido negar lo obvio.
José María Naharro-Calderón tiene
una forma de expresarse muy propia,
que hace pocas concesiones
a sus lectoras y lectores,
aunque es imposible
asociarle literalmente creo,
a ninguna corriente, determinado,
en una escuela determinada dentro
del campo, siempre he pensado que,
ha quedado marcado por el auge
de la alta teoría de los años 80,
en particular la de construcción
que la habrá pillado de lleno en su
fase formativa.
A estas alturas de derrydiano
[fonético] ya tiene muy poco,
pero si le ha quedado un gusto
por los juegos de palabras y la
invención de aparatos terminológicos
propios que el lector se tiene que
aprender y asimilar muy bien
para poder seguirle el argumento.
Para complicar las
cosas todavía más,
los términos que inventa José María
nunca tienen un solo significado o
valor, sino que suelen
activar varios a la vez.
Un buen ejemplo, es una fase
central en este libro la frase
"los monos de la desfachatez",
que sale en varios capítulos de
forma importante y para darles una
-- para daros una idea, de --
cómo estos términos funcionan,
voy a permitirme leer el pasaje de
la introducción en que José María
define "monos de la
desfachatez" como término central.
"Quiero construir - dice --
una imagen polisémica que retomo
semánticamente a partir de Teresa
Vilarós, el mono del desencanto,
e Ignacio Sánchez-Cuenca que
hace dos años publicó un libro,
'La desfachatez intelectual',
pero sin ceñirme a significado
que le dan esos autores,
aquí 'mono' se refiere por un lado
a -- y aquí cita la Real Academia --
a la obsesiva necesidad apremiante
o añoranza de reclamar o echar en
falta que identificaremos
entre diversos discursos de la
insatisfacción actual,
algunos nostálgicamente
republican los exilios".
Entonces el mono es ese anhelo.
Por otro, dice, "es prenda de
vestir de una sola pieza --
el mono azul, ¿no?, o sea,
el mono, el mono, de vestir --
que evoca también el uniforme de
los milicianos republicanos de la
Guerra Civil.
Lo utiliza en este sentido como
metáfora de la longevidad de
discursos republicanos de exilios
y de la buena salud de opciones
discursivas demagógicas que
también contaminaron el idealismo de
aquellos que se opusieron
al fascismo en el 36.
También conservó el mono, la
acepción de síndrome de abstinencia,
en referencia a los problemas
acarreados por ciertos olvidos de la
transición como el de los exilios
de las Españas o de una de sus
metonimias de ausencias, las
fosas comunes del franquismo y la
embriaguez o borrachera, otra
definición de la Real Academia,
por los excesos que acarrean
las inframemorias históricamente
gremiales reprimidas a favor de
los perdedores y sus víctimas.
Por desfachatez, en su sentido
de descaro o desvergüenza,
pienso en los discursos reparadores
y llenos de recetas inconsistentes y
demagógicamente líquidas y ligeras,
que pueden plantearse desde una
postura de supuesta ecuanimidad y
equidistancia históricamente
reductora en revisionista y aquí se
refiere a Javier Cercas,
Andrés Trapiello,
Arturo Pérez-Reverte, etcétera.
Como también de seldo-negacionismo
nietzscheano,
radicalmente destructor, anclado
en una historia nostálgicamente
anticuaria, y aquí cita a Gregorio
Morán, Juan Carlos Monedero,
Vicenç [fonético] Navarro, etcétera.
Entonces, aquí tenemos para mí
una definición típica, ¿no?,
una frase que estructura el
libro, les parece una frase,
frase sencilla, pero incluye en sí
misma, todo, todo, una posesión,
una visión, una perspectiva,
que guía y que estructura el libro
entero y la visión entera del
profesor Naharro sobre
lo que es el exilio,
el problema de la memoria
en la España actual y,
quizás en el futuro.
Pero "Entre alambradas" no sólo
es difícil a nivel estilístico y
terminológico, es sobre todo,
quizás difícil porque es incómodo.
Es un libro muy incómodo.
No hace concesiones
estilísticas, como ya dije,
pero hace todavía menos
concesiones a nivel de contenido.
El libro se niega a complacer a
nadie y mantiene esa postura de una
forma casi exasperadamente
consistente durante todo el libro.
Entonces, promulga muchas verdades
pero ninguna de ellas consuela.
Si uno entra, por ejemplo, al
libro con determinadas ideas y
convicciones, por ejemplo, con
respecto a la Guerra Civil,
o al exilio, o al franquismo, a la
transición, a la memoria histórica,
es muy difícil que esas ideas
sobrevivan después de esa lectura.
Digamos, por ejemplo, que a uno
le gusta pensar que España es
excepcional por la escandalosa
impunidad que todavía rodea al
franquismo y los crímenes
del franquismo,
y que uno deriva cierto
placer de indignarse por esta
escandalosa situación.
Chema típicamente se empeña en
aguarnos la fiesta de la indignación
moral, -- "lo siento -- dice
-- estáis equivocados - dice --
hay que desterrar la falacia tan
difundida de la excepcionalidad
española ante la falta de justicia,
así lo escribe del franquismo o de
la exhumación de las fosas comunes,
como lo muestra Abraham [inaudible]
los crímenes de masa no han sido
perseguidos prácticamente nunca,
mientras que representa la
vasta mayoría de las violencias
planetarias sin ningún tipo de
reparación o localización de
las víctimas.
Paradójicamente, incluso, cuando
son investigados o juzgados en su
mayoría sólo tocan a un
pequeño grupo de responsables".
Así también, nos hace
ver, por ejemplo,
que la idea de la comisión
de la verdad,
tampoco tiene mucho
sentido en España hoy.
"Lo que no significa
sin embargo - dice --
que no podamos destacar la
importancia de la voz callada de los
muertos" eso es otra cosa.
Otra forma de decir todo esto es
que Naharro se niega al cierre
conceptual o histórico.
En un pasaje del capítulo seis,
describe el valor de los textos
de Max Aub, que es un valor,
que me parece, él busca también
busca emular, y de hecho lo hace.
La obra de Aub dice "vaticina
la actualidad de la irresolución
vivencial y memoriosa
sobre la guerra civil,
la atención sobre los espacios rotos
de la memoria del conflicto y la
imposibilidad de restañar
completamente dicho resguardo
mediante un discurso teleológico,
asumible y concluyente".
Entonces no hay cierra
posible, no hay solución.
Como intelectuales, Aub y
Naharro, se mueven, se mueven,
en palabras de Naharro, entre la
esperanza de la comprensión y el
escepticismo de la resolución.
Así, por ejemplo, también invoca la
palabra exilio disness [fonético],
para referirse a la forma en que,
sobre todo en los últimos 15 años,
el exilio como fenómeno
recuperable lo ha sido sólo,
una especie de forma limpiada,
deshecha de sus, de sus,
aspectos más difíciles,
más problemáticos,
para compensar por la falta de
procesamiento de las fosas comunes
en España.
Entonces el exilio es una
especie de espectáculo,
del exilio convertido en un
espectáculo fácilmente importable y
asumible por una España que en
realidad no asume su propio pasado.
Ah, así también, por ejemplo,
habla del exilio mexicano, ¿no?,
que el exilio mexicano, muy
mitificado y dice, bueno,
si te pones a pensar, los exiliados
de México no vivían tan mal, ¿no?,
y eran relativamente privilegiados,
aunque desde ese privilegio,
por ejemplo, a la segunda generación
de exiliados construyen una
mitología propia del sufrimiento,
y de añoranza, y de nostalgia,
pero no hay que perder de
vista su agradecido privilegio.
Bien. He dicho que es un libro
disidente, reconoce como nadie,
que el relato de la
guerra, del exilio,
del franquismo y de la transición
es un campo de batalla político.
Pero de la misma forma que se niega
a promulgar verdades que consuelen,
se niega a afiliarse con ninguno de
los muchos actores en ese campo de
batalla político que es la
memoria del siglo 20 español.
Obviamente no está con el Partido
Popular ni con [inaudible],
tampoco está, ni mucho menos con
escritores como Javier Cercas,
Andrés Trapiello o
Pérez-Reverte, que,
desenmascara constantemente
como malabaristas,
como falsificadores o impostores.
Pero tampoco está con esa parte
de la izquierda española que,
sobre todo, desde el año 2011,
se empeña en criticar la transición
y reivindicar el legado del
republicano del exilio, es decir,
tampoco está con Juan
Carlos Monedeo,
con Vicenç [fonético] Navarro,
ni con ningún otro intelectual
orgánico de, Unidos Podemos.
No está obviamente con los
centralistas españoles,
pero tampoco está con
los catalanistas,
recuerda por ejemplo que
los refugiados del 39,
cuya memoria ha intentado
monopolizar Cataluña, por ejemplo,
en el museo memorial de l'Exili eran
en su mayoría castellano parlante,
en parte porque venían de
muchas partes de la península;
y también nos recuerda que el
fotógrafo Agustí Centelles,
un tanto comunista y comprometido
con la causa republicana no se
identificaba políticamente
como catalán.
No está con los franceses,
que se empeñan en distinguir sus
campos de internamiento [fonético],
de los campos de concentración
o exterminio nazis.
Y tampoco está siempre con los
mexicanos que se ufanan de la
generosidad con que recibieron
a los exiliados españoles.
Esta postura profunda y genuinamente
disidente del profesor Naharro,
me parece que se arraiga
en dos principios.
El primero es un principio,
quizás el principio del
investigador humanista,
nunca dejar de cuestionar
nada, siempre complicarlo todo,
siempre resistir la tentación
de la simplificación.
El segundo, es un compromiso ético
formulado quizás mejor por Max Aub
que definía al intelectual como
aquella persona para quien los
problemas políticos,
son problemas morales.
Finalmente he dicho que
este libro es desbordante.
Es difícil, disidente y desbordante.
Lo es en su forma más literal, no
cabe en sí, literalmente, no cabe.
La edición impresa con sus casi 500
páginas grandes con letras pequeñas,
no contiene todos los
capítulos, [risas],
hay otros tres que quedaron fuera,
[risas], en palabras del autor,
han sido desplazados, [risas],
para la versión final de este
libro debido a cuestiones reales
de longitud.
En otras palabras se han quedado
exiliados [risas] y su país en el
refugio es el blog, muy básico,
del autor donde viven precariamente
asilados como PDF [risas].
Si los capítulos no
caben en el libro,
las ideas no caben en
los capítulos, [risas],
no hay casi página que no
tenga largas notas al pie con
definiciones, explicaciones,
polémicas, discursos.
La bibliografía tiene
más de 50 páginas,
y mejor no hablar de la lista de
correcciones, enmiendas, etcétera,
etcétera, que sigue creciendo
todos los días, [risas].
Es difícil resistir la tentación
de leer este desbordamiento,
esta especie de horror
vacui, como síntoma,
o al menos como clave para
comprender la personalidad
del autor.
Me parece que dice mucho de
Chema Naharro como intelectual.
No hay libro que no haya leído,
no hay idea que no quiera incluir,
de rigor este libro vale del exilio
del republicano pero en el fondo su
ambición es totalizante universal,
no es que pretenda abarcar todos
los temas posibles de una forma,
cumulativa, sino que
como los fractales,
en cierto sentido cualquiera
de los párrafos,
cualquiera de las páginas
refleja esa afán de totalidad.
A mí personalmente las dimensiones
de la erudición desplegadas en estas
páginas, así como el afán de
comprensión y conocimiento,
me dejan pasmado completamente.
Para terminar, un texto exílico,
y creo que este texto
es un texto exílico.
Quizás la forma más fácil de
ilustrar este punto es hacerse una
pregunta sencilla, ¿este libro se
pudiera haber escrito en España?,
digo lo podría haber escrito una
persona que pasara toda su vida en
el ámbito institucional de
la universidad española,
a mí me parece que
no, su dificultad,
su disidencia y su desbordamiento
reflejan una perspectiva desplazada
porque, por un lado, la intensidad y
afectividad de su interés por España
y su cultura son las de una persona
que se siente y sabe español,
por otro la nitidez de su visión
crítica refleja una distancia que
tiene que haber sido física,
cultural y de largo plazo.
Para citar la frase que Naharro usa
para describir de nuevo a Max Aub,
y a Eugenio Imaz [inaudible]
Mora y Zambrano, y Simprúm,
lo que busca es una escritura
crítico-ética de lucidez desterrada,
de lucidez desterrada.
Esto me lleva a un punto final que
quizás puede servir como punto de
discusión después, desde que se
establecieron las disciplinas
académicas en el siglo XIX,
el conocimiento humanista sobre la
península ibérica sobre el estado
español, se ha producido en España
pero una gran parte se ha producido
fuera de España, ¿no?, no es
casual que la palabra hispanista,
la usemos para referirnos
generalmente a expertos de España
que no están en España,
que son extranjeros o que
viven fuera de España.
No todos han sido extranjeros,
¿no?,
a menos de este blanco-white
[phonetic],
hay cantidad de españoles que han
salido de España para escribir o
estudiar España.
De hecho, hay cada vez más, mi
compañero Germán Labrador Méndez,
aquí, acaba de publicar un libro
que todo el mundo, también,
tiene que leer, después de
haberse leído el de Chema [risas],
que también es un libro un
poco desbordante, [risas],
por cierto [risas],
tiene un prólogo,
una introducción preciosa en
que habla un poco de su propia
circunstancia vital que no
puedo por menos de asociar,
[ruido micrófono] perdón, de la
generación del profesor Naharro,
dice Germán -- sin desearlo
formé parte de una generación de
investigadores que a pesar de sus
aportaciones en sus respectivos
campos, lejos de haber sido
aprovechados por el mundo del que
proceden fueron alejados
de él con violencia,
como gallego sé de la antigüedad
de esas rutas y por eso lo digo con
más desconcierto que tristeza, pero
también con un espíritu cívico.
Desde 2008 he participado en muchos
procesos evaluadores en España y
Estado Unidos y conozco las
dimensiones de la diáspora.
Parecería a veces que la función
de las universidades en el estado
Español consistiese en la doma o
desperdicio del talento más joven.
No lo digo sólo como humanista,
pues nuestros saberes parecen
siempre sometidos a duda,
la sangría de talento
afecta por igual a técnicos,
científicos y trabajadores
precarios.
Y no se trata de lo que estas
gentes puedan o podamos merecer,
sino de un futuro que se marcha con
ellas por los caminos desconocidos y
una globalización neoliberal,
con sus múltiples centros
y múltiples periferias.
Y en relación con la vida que se
podría desear para un rincón idílico
del mundo.
Así la maternidad primera de este
trabajo de su libro, de Germán,
dependió, un día de la, un día de la
inversión pública del estado español
y de sus contribuyentes,
pero el desarrollo posterior de
mis investigaciones ha sido posible
gracias a la Universidad
de Princeton --
, etcétera, etcétera, ¿no?
Ahora ese legado de expulsiones y
la tradición del trabajo hispanista
desde fuera, ha producido, creo,
una [inaudible] actual
que es paradójica.
Por un lado, sobre todo en
el campo de la historia,
el saber de fuera tiene todavía
un prestigio, un capital,
un capital cultural muy importante.
Cada vez que un experto de fuera
pasa por España o dice algo sobre
España, es dada, es dado una
importancia bastante importante.
Pensemos en [inaudible], Paul
Preston, Kerel [fonético] Jackson,
¿no?, es gente que tiene un
capital cultural importante.
Por otro lado, hay también too un
cuerpo de conocimiento humanista
producido sobre España, fuera de
España, que en España no es leído,
no llega, es bastante ignorado y no
conecta sobre todo con los mismos
campos en principio humanistas
tal y como se practican en España.
Pensando en ésta --
en esta situación,
yo me pregunto ¿qué podemos hacer?,
¿qué se puede hacer?, para que,
ese importantísimo trabajo que
tenemos aquí en el libro de José
María Naharro-Calderón para
que cuele, para que llegue,
para que impacte, donde debería
impactar, que es en España.
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Eyda Merediz: Muchas,
muchas gracias al profesor Faber por
esta intervención y por darnos una
radiografía del libro y
una écfrasis del autor,
que también experimentamos en los
emails que nos manda de vez en
cuando, [risas], que son
desbordantes, [risas].
Este, ahora le doy la palabra
al profesor Germán Labrador.
>> Germán Labrador:
¿Sí?, ¿se me escucha?
¿Se me escucha bien?
Si. Bueno, nada, muchas gracias,
quiero empezar agradeciendo,
José María esta invitación,
es un verdadero placer estar
aquí en este sitio tan bonito,
esta librería fantástica,
con Sebastián [inaudible] cosas
que dice, y con todas vosotras,
celebrando este libro nuevo,
mandar un libro al mundo,
no siempre es motivo
de orgullo, ¿no?,
pero en este caso además de orgullo,
es motivo de agradecimiento, ¿no?
Entonces, gracias por la invitación,
pero sobre todo por haber
hecho ese libro posible,
hoy es un día de celebración, he
oído también que una happy hour,
también, [risas], y, bueno, pues
eso es una maravilla formar parte
de eso.
Yo no tengo tanta confianza
con José María,
entonces no podré ser tan
irónico como Sebastián, [risas],
pero veo que algunas de las cosas
que sí que voy a decir que resuenan,
¿no?, una parte de ellas, sí,
efectivamente tiene que ver con,
digamos, con la écfrasis, ¿no?,
del libro, otras partes de ellas,
más bien un intento de devolver, o
sea, lo que -- mi primera reacción,
lo que el libro ya está
haciendo, para mí, en mí trabajo,
no es que no quiera
hablar del libro,
es que quiero devolver de alguna
manera al trabajo que he hecho del
libro, como qué me
está ayudando a pensar,
qué me está enseñando a pensar,
y ahí hay algunas imágenes que
abordaré en los últimos minutos de
la presentación.
También os o quería decir,
comenzar diciendo que
"Entre alambradas y exilios" es un
gran libro en el más físico sentido
de la palabra, y lo dice
una persona como Sebastián,
también ha dicho que ama hacer
libros grandes y excesivos, ¿no?
Lo digo con admiración, ¿no?,
porque creo que las estructuras
académicas en las que habitamos no
benefician necesariamente
este tipo de proyectos,
hechos con más ambición, pasión,
que cálculo académico, no son,
pues los proyectos que
necesariamente se van a capitalizar,
entre otras cosas porque llevan
mucho tiempo hacerlos, ¿no?
Estamos hablando de más de 500
páginas de letra muy pequeña y con
conocimiento muy grande, con
una bibliografía rica, compleja,
unas notas a pie de
páginas increíbles y, eso,
con una extensión que se prolonga
más allá del propio volumen físico
hacia el espacio digital, ¿no?
Todavía puede haber una versión más
compleja y más completa del libro.
Esto lo digo con admiración,
en el sentido de que es evidente
de que aquí hay un trabajo de años,
esto no se hace en un
período corto de tiempo,
de hecho es un trabajo
de décadas, ¿no?,
y más allá de la propia organización
del libro, de sus capítulos,
de la investigación es toda
la trayectoria previa, ¿no?
Esto es un libro que está dialogando
con una trayectoria muy coherente en
el campo del hispanismo, ¿no?,
entonces es una vida, ¿no?,
es un libro de vida realmente,
lo que no excluye que haya
otros libros de vida, ¿no?,
pero éste lo es, ¿no?, y me parece
que es importante mencionar eso,
que hay una dimensión afectiva
muy importante detrás de la propia
posibilidad del proyecto, ¿no?,
de involucrarse con un tema
de una manera muy personal,
pensando que el trabajo que estás
haciendo es importante para la
propia supervivencia incluso del
objeto, es una cuestión de cuidados,
¿no?, yo creo que aquí
hay un trabajo del cuidado,
de tomar cuidado, de cuidar,
un mundo que estás estudiando
porque lo amas y porque crees que es
importante que siga
existiendo, ¿no?
Entonces, bueno a los estudiantes
graduados que estáis aquí,
no intentéis hacer esto en casa
al principio de vuestras carreras,
[risas], pero algún día puede ser
que llegue, si lo toman seriamente,
acabará sucediendo,
pero no necesariamente dentro
de la escuela graduada.
No es fácil, tampoco, resumir los
temas del libro porque se expanden,
mutan en diferente direcciones,
van conectando otras discusiones,
otros archivos, creo que eso
es parte de su potencia, ¿no?,
no renunciar a las visiones
globales, a la complejidad,
a convocar mundos, a situar lo que
de específico y de particular hay en
cada cosa, lo que significa, pues,
de repente hacer unos grandes,
unos zoom out y después unos
focalizaciones muy concretas,
podemos decir que de alguna manera
el tema tiene que ver con el legado
de la experiencia, creo que la
experiencia es una palabra clave,
¿no?, en el archivo, no siempre la
gente que trabaja en el ámbito de
los estudios culturales focaliza
las experiencias, tendemos, ¿no?,
a dejarnos desviar por
las representaciones,
pero aquí no hay un intento
realmente de hablar, de apropiarse,
de trasmitir, también una
experiencia a partir, sí,
de digamos de los restos
materiales que la hacen posible,
de la cultura que la conforma y ahí
aparece todo el archivo mutante,
flotante de los exilios, de
la experiencia republicana,
de la Guerra Civil y sus
consecuencias concentracionarias en
el espacio fundamentalmente francés
antes la guerra mundial, ¿no?
No sólo también luego se complica
por otros campos, por otros exilios,
por otras diásporas, pero un
poco esa zona in between, ¿no?,
la Guerra Civil Española
y la guerra mundial,
y por supuesto ese [inaudible]
también de los campos de muerte
alemanes, aparecen otras
experiencias que tienen que ver con
el exilio, con la experiencia
concentracionaria,
con la experiencia necropolítica
[fonético] y el libro de alguna
manera trata de hacerse
cargo de ellas, ¿no?,
visto porque esa memoria histórica
hay un capital moral para la
democracia, ¿no?
De una manera digamos, abriendo
un paréntesis, yo diré que sí,
que hay una frecuencia
utópica de alguna manera,
latiendo por debajo del libro,
después de la descripción
que ha hecho Sebastián,
uno podría pensar que es muy fácil
que un libro así acabe siendo
nihilista o acabe de alguna
manera enrocándose en un lugar,
pues de alejamiento del mundo,
pero no creo que ese sea el
afecto que domina en el libro,
como también un poco
Sebastián ha dicho, ¿no?,
en términos de humanismos,
¿sí?, pues,
ese humanismo que también
es utopista, ¿no?,
hay una pulsión hacia una democracia
por venir, derriana, quizás,
pero yo sí creo que hay alguna
pequeña efectividad, ¿sí?,
con algún actor del campo de
la memoria de la política,
se acercaría, digamos, sería
más bien como ese mundo del 15M,
de los indignados, yo allí veo una
frecuencia indignada al fondo del
libro, ¿no?
Particularmente me llamó
la atención una frase,
a propósito de las
alambradas digitales,
que incivilizaban y que permitían
de alguna manera la gestión de la
protesta y de las nuevas formas
de protestas, en las ciudades,
en las metrópolis de
capitalismo global, ¿no?
En este sentido, bueno, como digo,
al centro del libro está la
experiencia y la cultura de las
diásporas republicanas, tal
y como fue representada o no,
por observadores de primera
mano, historiadores, testimonios,
ficciones, fotografías
y crónicas, ¿no?
Aquí encontramos a los sospechosos
habituales del archivo del exilio,
de Bolsa [fonético] a Centelles,
de Capa a Chaves Nogales,
de Mistral a Semprúm, pero también
son invitados a la fiesta los chicos
malos de los debates de la memoria
en la España de hoy como Javier
Cercas, Andrés Trapiello y
[inaudible] Gracia a los que,
desde luego, no creo que les vaya
a gustar mucho el libro ni lo que
dicen de ellos.
Particularmente concuerdo, además,
con la interpretación de
soldados [fonético] a la mina,
fue una alegría descubrir esa
sintonía, también en la lectura.
Pero si hay una escritura del exilio
que realmente centra la discusión
del libro, es como también indicó
Sebastián, la de Max Aub, ¿no?,
hay unas páginas increíbles
dedicadas a Max Aub,
lo que ya estaríamos en el ámbito
de una verdadera love story
intelectual, ¿no?
Aquí se ha hablado también de
imitación, yo no sé, yo creo --
yo no planteo los términos,
más bien hay un enamoramiento,
hay realmente aquí un asunto, un
asunto con Max Aub que excede,
digamos lo razonable, como fan
también absoluto de Max Aub,
me siento bien incluido, ¿no?
Y creo que tiene que ver también,
con la posición ética, moral,
política de Max Aub y de su
testimonio que en palabras de Rafael
Chirbes, ¿no?, como ¿quién
se come a Max Aub?, ¿no?,
como ese autor cuya posición
es imposible ser devorada,
es imposible de ser apropiada,
es imposible de ser desmenuzada,
esa especie de roca de la
memoria y del compromiso.
Hay páginas bellísimas en el
libro, y he aprendido muchísimo,
estoy aprendiendo, tengo
que seguir aprendiendo,
es un libro al que hay que
volver, ¿no?, como las dedicadas,
por ejemplo, a la relación de
Juan Ramón Jiménez y el entonces
vicepresidente norteamericano
Henry Wallace,
que habría representado una salida
distinta a la postguerra mundial,
no basada en términos de guerra
fría sino más bien en términos de
multipolarismo, la posibilidad de la
creación de un orden internacional
basado en la paz y la cooperación
donde habría tenido cabida una
España republicana
y democrática, ¿no?
Entonces, en esos diálogos,
que son diálogos poéticos,
que son diálogos utópicos
y políticos,
hay también una historia
alternativa posible del siglo 20.
Me fascina también la
sensibilidad de José María,
cuando trabaja con los testimonios,
¿no?, muchas veces a pie de página,
efectivamente en esos capítulos
enteros que son las notas a pie de
página hay ejemplos, hay testimonios
que tienen el potencial de
convertirse, no de -- en
películas, pero quizás, sí,
en comienzos de películas.
Recuerdo, por cierto, uno,
que era la historia de un preso
español en un campo de trabajo,
es más no recuerdo, en
el norte de África,
que asesinó secretamente
a su carcelero alemán,
un sádico terrible, tirándole
una carretilla de piedras,
desde la montaña, ¿no?, mientras
los demás presos miraban para otro
lado, ¿no?
Hay como escenas realmente
de una potencia,
contadas de la voz de las
propias personas, ¿no?,
lo que yo entiendo es que es
una estética y una ética de la
polifonía, no siempre
que aparece la polifonía,
estamos hablando de una
ética de la narración,
un compromiso con la pluralidad
y con la singularidad de la
experiencia histórica, reconociendo
las vidas humanas en lo que de
singular y específico tienen
las vidas anónimas, ¿no?,
en las voces anónimas, ¿no?, lo
que de singular, y de específico,
y de valioso hay en cada una
de esas experiencias, ¿no?
Los legados, como digo, ¿no?
Del sufrimiento, pero
también de la utopía,
de la experiencia de la
diáspora republicana,
de su deportación y
su encarcelamiento,
se vincula no sólo con
un archivo cultural,
sino también con una geografía,
una geopoética de fronteras,
tierras de nadie, límites,
una toponimia, ¿no?,
donde aparecen Yelfa
[fonético], aparece Vallecas,
y aparece Ariel [inaudible],
en una historia global del
horror y de la memoria,
de las políticas de memoria en la
cual la experiencia republicana
ocupa un espacio, muy, muy pequeño
pero crucial en su particular
experiencia y poner en
valor, lo que, digamos,
lo que de común hay en esa
experiencia respecto de la historia
universal del horror,
pero de lo que,
de específico me parece
muy importante.
Bueno, también, a propósito de
lo que eso tiene de reimaginar la
complejidad de lo ibérico,
desde ese hallazgo,
que es el término de las Españas,
que es el término desde que va a
anunciar todo el libro, verdad,
¿no?, esos exilios de las Españas
que es una solución fantástica con
la perspectiva del próximo
domingo, también, ¿no?,
cuando las Cataluñas tendrán que
decidir si pueden o no pueden votar,
¿no?
Pero el momento específicos que
ocupa la experiencia diaspórica y
concentracionaria, republicana,
en el contexto francés,
es clave para la discusión entre
totalitarismo y liberalismo,
democracia liberal en relación con
los estados modernos y la política,
las necropolíticas, ¿no?, o sea,
la pregunta hasta qué punto
la lógica concentracionaria,
como han argumentado muchos,
entre otros Agandem [fonético],
tiene que ver con una lógica
más profunda del estado moderno,
del capitalismo colonial y de
sus desarrollos tecnológicos,
no importa si los ciudadanos
votan o no.
En ese sentido, ¿no?,
de alguna manera,
ese argumento que es un argumento
implícito que se va desarrollando en
distinto momentos del libro,
nos conecta con el presente,
con la idea, ¿no?, de las
diásporas globales, contemporáneas,
de las nuevas formas de
necropolítica que son también una
parte actual de esa
historia que empieza,
que no empieza pero que se expresa
en los años 30 y 40 en este libro.
Yo no sé si hay un [inaudible]
detrás, cómo dice Sebastián,
yo veía más un fucono
[fonético] pero de alguna manera,
también se puede considerar parte de
ese momento mágico de la teoría de
los finales de los 70 y de los 80.
Un hecho que especialmente
me entusiasma del libro,
ya me voy dirigiendo un poco
hacia mi zona de las imágenes,
tiene que ver con el continuo
pasado-presente, ¿no?
Es un libro hecho con los pies en
el presente y los ojos en el pasado,
que es como yo creo que se
debe trabajar históricamente.
Una razón poderosa para hacer esto,
tienen que ver con el hecho de que
nuestro mundo está construido a
partir de aquellos
mundos de experiencia,
de guerra y de diáspora,
y por otro lado,
porque no es posible separar
el estudio de aquella cultura,
de su memoria, de su legado
de memoria, en el presente.
De alguna manera, a la hora
de discutir sobre memoria,
que es un tema como ya
Sebastián ha abierto,
muy central en las discusiones
españolas de los últimos años,
mueve el foco, digamos,
de la experiencia de las fosas
comunes o de la represión a pues
este espacio más difuso de los
territorios y las diásporas que nos
conectaría con una geografía actual
o que ya no sería Yelfa sino los
mercados de esclavos de Libia,
y ya no sería los campos del sur de
Francia sino los de Caleb [fonético]
o los [inaudible] de España,
o las [inaudible] de Melilla,
que son convocadas en el libro
en distintos momentos, ¿no?
Entonces yo entraría un poco desde
ahí, en el sentido de preguntarme,
hasta qué punto lo que este
libro ha montado, ha articulado,
nos permite ver hoy, ¿no?,
de qué manera podemos revalidar el
capital de solidaridad radical y
también de, ¿no?, las experiencias
[inaudible] complejas como son,
con sus áreas oscuras
y ambigüedades,
en el contexto presente
y hasta qué punto,
es importante hoy como entonces,
tomar cuidado de lo que José
María llama inframemorias,
y que yo pues prefiero referir
como memorias subalternas, ¿no?
Es decir, el drama de aquello que no
puede ser dicho públicamente o que
cuando se dice públicamente no
es reconocido es invisible, ¿no?
Entonces yo me tomo muy en serio,
ese diálogo presente y pasado
que nos propone el libro para
preguntarme ¿dónde está
hoy Max Aub?, ¿no?,
¿dónde está hoy Centelles?,
¿dónde está hoy Picasso?,
¿con quién está hablando hoy
Juan Ramón?, y ¿de qué país son?,
¿en qué lengua lo hacen?, ¿no?,
¿en qué sentido hay una estética,
una cultura, ocupándose de pensar,
de sobrevivir a los flujos de horror
y de dolor que están reconfigurando
las periferias del mundo occidental
y sus sociedades privilegiadas?
O dicho de otra manera ¿qué
podemos aprender?, ¿no?,
¿desde dónde podemos
aprender a mirar hoy,
esos flujos a partir de las
experiencias que José María ha
estudiado?, ¿no?
Hay como una cuestión, también,
digamos estructural que tiene que
ver con el cambio de lugar de lo
español en este tiempo, que
podemos situar, también,
en relación con la
transición democrática, ¿no?,
como que las fronteras se
han puesto en otro sitio.
Hoy los españoles tienen unos
pasaportes serios, respetables,
¿no?, como en los años 30, ¿no?,
y de alguna manera como que están
mirando ese mundo desde el otro lado
de la alambrada, ¿no?
Hay claramente un cambio
en la posición estructural,
geopolítica de la imaginación
del cuerpo político del español,
que ya digamos, ve él,
esas experiencias desde
otro lugar de la alambrada,
y como nos enseña José María,
la alambrada desde uno de los dos
lados, se hace invisible, ¿no?
Y entonces como dicen
los catalanes --
es aquí donde empieza el
mambo -- , ¿no?, [risas].
Como algunas imágenes os quería
traer en ese diálogo posible entre
presente y pasado con
el libro de José María,
tiene que ver con estos centros de
concentración actuales que son los
CIES [fonético] que son espacios
que quedan fuera de la organización
jurídica del estado español, que
no tienen un estatus legal claro,
donde la ley es suspendida,
donde no pueden entrar las ONG,
los jueces han tenido muchos
problemas para entrar,
donde no se pueden
hacer fotografías,
que están arquitectónicamente
diseñados para que no pueda haber
una circulación de imágenes del
interior al exterior, ¿no?,
y lo que sucede cuando, de repente,
esto es una fotografía
del otoño pasado, ¿no?,
de un motín en el CIE
de Aluche [fonético],
durante algunas horas los internos
consiguen tomar el tejado del CIE y
simple su objetivo es
que se les vea, o sea,
lo hacen para poder ser vistos, y
lo hacen con dos palabras, ¿no?,
libertad y, en árabe, egipcio,
[hablando idioma extranjero], ¿no?
Ese momento de volverse
visible, ¿no?,
me pareció increíblemente político,
porque por vez primera los internos
de los CIES tenían la capacidad de
hablar en público, ¿no?
Y aquí me venían, por supuesto,
imágenes de los campos franceses
e historias que el libro estaba
contando, ¿no?
Entre estas dos imágenes, ¿no?,
ésta y ésta, han pasado 35 años,
bueno como 40 años, perdón.
Esta es una imagen del 77 de
Carabanchel [fonético] es el mismo
barrio, los dos espacios están
a 500 metros, uno del otro,
esto es una huelga de la Copel
[fonético] en plena transición
democrática, porque la democracia es
una cosa que hemos fundamentalmente,
olvidado.
A comienzo de la democracia,
hubo huelgas generales en todas las
prisiones españolas reclamando las
mismas palabras, dignidad
y libertad, ¿no?
Y esto es una cuestión muy
importante, porque, digamos,
en la experiencia de los jóvenes
de la transición, ahí podemos ver,
libertad, ¿no?, con más precisión.
España era esto, la
España postfranquista,
era un gigantesco campo
de concentración, ¿no?,
era pensado con este lenguaje,
con estas imágenes, ¿no?,
el imaginario que ellos
utilizaban no es el de la consenso,
sobre el mito del consenso hay un
borrado de otras sangrías de las
Españas, de las Españas
en este caso juveniles,
contraculturales de los años 70, que
es un poco las que yo he estudiado.
Pero me parecía muy importante,
incorporar este otro
elemento también, digamos,
a qué es lo que le impide que la
España contemporánea pueda recuperar
sus diásporas de los
años 30, 40, 50.
Por un lado, un cambio geopolítico,
la frontera se pone más abajo,
los españoles tienen buenos
pasaportes; pero, por otro lado,
en el proceso de transición
democrática, hay un borrado,
una exclusión total de unas
experiencias de concentración,
de muerte, también de
diásporas, que no tiene relato,
que no pudieron incorporar ese
relato de los años 30 a pesar de que
hubiera habido en su
momento algunos diálogos.
-- Bueno, eso tiene
que ver con lo mismo --
Detrás del mito de la
transición del abrazo,
este es el famoso cartel
Genovés, ¿no?, de la amnistía 77,
se olvida lo que la
amnistía no incluye, ¿no?,
aquellos que sí se
quedan en las cárceles,
las cárceles van a seguir llenas.
Pero, sin embargo, hoy lo que me
interesa es que este imaginario
también permite de otros
diálogos que incorpora las
diásporas globales.
Esta es una pieza de
un artista actual,
Rafael Sánchez-Mateos Paniagua,
que se llama "Abrazo a la salida de
un CIE" que es un diálogo evidente
con la obra del genovés, pero desde
la reunificación de una familia
diaspórica marroquí en
España, ahora mismo,
que consiguen no ser deportado,
es el abrazo que se dan después de
haber conseguido que su familiar no
fuese deportado.
Por cierto, que la acción
evidentemente está medida por grupos
de activistas jóvenes españoles
vinculado al mundo del 15M.
Esta pieza fue enseñada en una
muestra que se llamaba tiempos de
alegría, tiempos de
desamparo, muy interesante,
que se mostró en varios lugares,
pero también en el
Ayuntamiento de Madrid,
en el edificio principal
del Ayuntamiento de Madrid,
con artistas de todo
el Mediterráneo,
muchos de ellos en la diáspora,
muchos de ellos en el exilio,
que reflejan lo que ha
sucedido desde el 2011,
desde las primaveras árabes,
y cómo el capital utópico colectivo
de aquel momento se ha diluido en
unas fugas contrarrevoluciones,
muertes, represión, ¿no?,
[inaudible] una sangrías de los
Magrebs [fonético] hoy en día,
¿no?, que están gritando
contra el silencio,
contra las terapias de la unión
europea del presente, ¿no?,
y la palabra también es interesante
que vuelve a ser dignidad,
¿no?, Al Karama [fonético].
Bueno, esto es parte del arte que
había en esa exposición, ¿no?,
trayendo las memorias de
las primaveras árabes.
En este sentido, una
cosa que aprendí,
que creo que para mí es la enseñanza
central a nivel teórico del libro de
José María, es que la experiencia
de la diáspora y de las políticas de
concentración a las que son
sometidos los diaspóricos,
no mata la experiencia histórica
de las luchas de la emancipación
democrática, al contrario la
preserva, es una paradoja,
y la preserva a través
de la estética.
Y me sirve esa paradoja, ¿no?,
de que la estética puede guardar en
el campo la experiencia por la lucha
de la emancipación a través de la
memoria, me sirve también para leer,
pues los campos utópicos, las
ciudades utópicas, del 2011,
esto es el campamento del sol
en Madrid y los campos de Calais
[fonético], los campos de acogida
en Francia y no sólo en Grecia,
en otros espacios, en Italia,
donde aparecen los mismos carteles,
el mismo vocabulario, las
mismas demandas, ¿no?
Este mismo artista, Rafael
Sánchez-Mateos Paniagua,
hizo una pieza este
verano muy interesante,
que era "Esto es lo real",
se llama, "Esto es lo real",
donde de alguna manera, no
sé qué está surgiendo ahí --
>> Tiene batería baja.
>> Germán Labrador: Sí, bueno,
de todos modos ya voy
a ir, este, acabando.
O sea, la idea de que, dentro del
campo, dentro del campamento --
es el campamento del sol pero
reconvertido también en un
campamento de refugiados y de
alguna manera la proximidad,
la continuidad, de ambas formas.
Hay toda una cultura en los campos
de refugiados hoy en día, o sea,
hay un arte que preserva
unas experiencias,
que cuida unas vidas en la
diáspora y en las desasistidas,
en la jungla de Calais
había bibliotecas públicas,
igual que en el campamento del
sol, a través de la decoración,
las casas, las chabolas [fonético]
adquieren dignidad, ¿no?,
los grafitis o tienen la capacidad
de construir una buena vida, o sea,
la estética sirve para la
construcción de una buena vida para
los adultos, pero también
para los niños,
los niños de los campos de
hoy siguen dibujando, ¿no?,
por citar aquello famoso título del
libro de [inaudible] sobre el arte
español de los niños de España, de
las Españas de la diáspora, ¿no?
El arte sigue hoy siendo
un útil, también,
para representar su situación,
esto es toda una instalación
en Calais sobre el purgatorio,
de alguna manera se representa
dentro del purgatorio,
el purgatorio, ¿no?
Usan imágenes para denunciar las
desapariciones que se están hoy en
día produciendo en Europa,
los asesinatos extrajudiciales que
se están produciendo hoy en día de
inmigrantes, ¿no?
Por supuesto, hoy como
entonces, ¿no?,
hay artistas que miran el arte
desde un lado o desde otro de las
alambradas, ¿no?, hoy hay un
Capa que a lo mejor se llamaba
[inaudible], ¿no?, y hay artistas
anónimos dentro de los campos de los
que no sabemos ni sus nombres, pero
el motivo del barco de la medusa,
la danza de la medusa [inaudible]
de la [inaudible] se ha vuelto una
tropología central de los
exilios actuales europeos, ¿no?
Y aquí, bueno, se puede cerrar
el argumento porque es desde esta
perspectiva, donde a lo mejor sí se
está produciendo un diálogo con las
diásporas republicanas a
través de sus imágenes, ¿no?
Aquí aparece Picasso, en
medio del Mediterráneo,
una especie de [inaudible],
nótese al fondo el crucero turístico
que va a Barcelona o a Ámsterdam,
¿no?, como esta combinación de
las diásporas contemporáneas y los
turismos globales.
Y Max Aub también está ahí, ¿no?,
en el concepto de idiocia
[fonético] política,
el sol o en un libro
de Santiago Alba Rico,
leer con niños que es muy importante
en los pensamientos alternativos de
este ciclo, que se inicia con una
frase de campo francés, ¿no?,
¿para qué sirven los
niños?, ¿no?, entonces,
como quizás hay una conversación
secreta entre exilios, ¿no?
Hay un argumento que también desliza
José María, que tiene que ver --
y con esto voy a cerrar --
con la ausencia de xenofobia en el
espacio público y en el espacio de
la representación política
en España,
es un argumento complicado porque
por supuesto que hay racismo y hay
muchas problemáticas vinculadas
con la marginación del extranjero,
cuestiones también de odio
racial y de violencia,
pero lo que sí que es cierto,
es que España como quizás,
sólo puedo pensar en el caso de
Portugal de manera clara en el
ámbito europeo actual, no
ha articulado un discurso,
ningún partido ha articulado
un discurso público racista con
eficacia, en el espacio
público, ¿no?, no funciona,
no significa que no haya partidos
políticos racistas, que los hay,
no significa que no haya
políticas públicas racistas,
significa que no se pueden
nombrar públicamente.
Fenómenos como los que están
sucediendo en Grecia o en Alemania,
no se ha reproducido en España y
de alguna manera, en algún momento,
José María sugiere, ¿no?, que
allí hay una herencia subalterna.
Yo creo que sí, que la hay,
yo creo que sí, que la hay.
Abrevio, hay una imagen -- con
esta y la siguiente cierro --
que tiene que ver, este es
el Ayuntamiento de Madrid,
es una pancarta con la
misma estética del 15M,
donde ponen "Bienvenidos
refugiados", ¿no?
No sé cuántos ayuntamientos
más en el mundo, alguno hay,
si alguno más hay, tenemos la
potencia política y estética de este
gesto, que evidentemente nos trae
otras pancartas a la memoria,
ese es un gesto memorial también,
pero de una memoria muy interesante
porque hay unos desplazamientos,
también intenta fetichizarnos,
son palabras distintas,
son significados distintos,
pero hay un eco estético, ¿no?
Y ya termino con estas imágenes que
es la manifestación de este mes de
febrero en Barcelona,
la manifestación más
masiva de este año,
en defensa de la llegada
de los refugiados,
hubo más personas reivindicando
la llegada de los refugiados que
pidiendo votar la semana pasada.
No significa que sean dos
posiciones incompatibles,
pero digo que la capacidad de
movilización en términos de
políticas de acogida de la Barcelona
actual, de la Cataluña actual,
pues algo se recuerda por ahí de los
exilios y las diásporas españolas.
Entonces, nada, simplemente esto es
un ejemplo práctico de cómo estoy
aprendiendo del trabajo
increíble que ha hecho José María.
Y de nuevo, pues nada, abrir
la conversación y agradecer
la invitación.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Eyda Merediz: Muchas gracias
al profesor Labrador por habernos
recontextualizado el libro y por
abrirlo a un debate muy actual,
y antes de darle la
palabra al profesor Naharro,
que espero que tenga algo que decir
sobre la presentación y abrir el
foro a preguntas, quiero
dosificar las gracias un poco,
porque así tienen más efecto.
Gracias a los colegas del
departamento de español y portugués
de Maryland por estar aquí; a
nuestros estudiantes graduados,
también; colegas de la Universidad
de Virginia, gracias por venir;
colegas de la Universidad
Católica, también;
colegas del departamento de
Francés, gracias por venir.
Y, sobre todo quiero dar las gracias
a nuestros asistentes graduados,
a Sara Downma [fonético] que es
la responsable por el afiche,
y sobre todo a Daniela Polanski
[fonético] que ha estado detrás de
toda la organización.
Además a Janelle Brennan [fonético]
y a Jeff Marre [fonético] que son
responsables de que
esto se esté grabando y
trasmitiendo abiertamente.
Y sin más, pues quiero dar la
palabra al profesor Naharro y espero
que no sea demasiado
desbordante, porque, [risas],
tenemos que salir de esta
habitación aproximadamente,
10 minutos para las 5,
porque estamos en territorio
del Gobierno Federal, [risas].
Profesor Naharro.
>> José María Naharro-Calderón:
Muchas gracias.
Yo no me voy a levantar, porque todo
el mundo estamos sentados y esto
funciona, ¿no?, ¿se me
escucha?, así, más o menos.
Bueno, bueno, todos podéis imaginar
y voy a tutear, la confianza obliga.
Que este es un momento en la vida de
una persona, de cualquier persona,
y en la vida en particular, de
la persona que se está hablando,
que se está dirigiendo en
estos momentos a vosotros.
Es el momento más emotivo
de mi vida.
Porque estoy en un lugar,
estamos todos en el lugar,
en uno de los lugares, en el
lugar más simbólico del mundo,
para nosotros que nos dedicamos
a, que tenemos la suerte,
la enorme suerte de
dedicarnos a pensar, a escribir,
a tener la suerte de que
algunos seres cordiales,
algunas almas cordiales, se tragan
tocho [fonético] como éste, [risas],
entre otras cosas, infumable.
Es decir, hay que condenar,
¿no?, a gentes como yo,
a la eternidad de escribir esto
en un lenguaje que sea accesible,
¿no?, a cualquier ser humano,
y en estos momentos --
todo evidentemente le
viene a uno a la cabeza,
y evidentemente hay que buscar,
seleccionar de todo
aquello que se te agolpa,
pero yo creo que efectivamente, si,
lo que han destacado con
muchísima generosidad,
con muchísima generosidad,
y desde luego también con
muchísimo conocimiento,
con muchísima perspicacia,
con muchísima inteligencia,
estos dos, muy, muy,
muy, muy destacados,
miembros de efectivamente,
de este hispanismo en el cual a
lo mejor yo tengo un sitio junto a
ellos, y que pertenecen a la
continuidad de esas generaciones,
porque al fin y al cabo, y esto
de alguna forma se ha terminado
montando ad hoc, ¿no?
Sebastián pertenece, ¿no?,
digamos quizás a la generación
que me continúa, y Germán,
quizás es la generación que
viene detrás de Sebastián,
y hay aquellos que
están por encima de mí,
Vandolph [fonético] ha
tenido entre otras cosas,
a diferencia de venir
hoy a escucharnos.
Y lo primero que tiene uno que hacer
en este momento es, sobre todo,
un ejercicio de generosidad
y de agradecimiento,
porque uno no es nada, absolutamente
nada, como sabemos, uno es un átomo,
una micro, micro, micro de átomo
y en un universo que no
entendemos en realidad.
Y yo me pasmo naturalmente ante las
grandes mentes de nuestra época que
intentan trabajar nuestros orígenes,
que piensan en términos en los
cuales nosotros pobres humanistas,
no estamos en muchos casos
capacitados para entender o seguir.
Como digo que tenemos
todavía, ¿no?,
la certidumbre de que existen,
estos lugares, estos tenáculos,
llenos de libros que nos remonta
a la historia de los tiempos y que
cordialmente en este caso, a mí, en
particular, me remontan a un mundo,
ahí está, en esa sencilla mesa
que han puesto para vosotros todo
nuestro agradecimiento de la
Hispanic Division de la Biblioteca
del Congreso, unos pequeños
incunables hechos de la forma más
rudimentaria, y que los exiliados
españoles en ese camino difícil
pero, también para algunos,
algunos mejores que otros,
lograron hacer en México,
ese primer ejemplar de
"Éxodo" de Silvia Mistral,
que tengo la suerte de tener un
primer ejemplar que me regaló la
hija de Silvia Mistral,
Silvia [inaudible].
O esa sala de espera,
con la que Aub soñaba,
que en algún momento la suerte de
aquellos republicanos iba a cambiar.
Llevar la mano a esos libros, el
tener la capacidad de haber pensado,
de haber vivido, de
haberte puesto los cuernos,
mi querida mujer, con esas palabras.
>> Te perdono, [risas].
>> José María Naharro-Calderón:
Efectivamente,
tengo una love story [risas], con
algunos autores, gracias Germán,
por haber, por lo menos, ¿verdad?,
evitado una pelea familiar, ¿no?,
[risas], por lo menos podemos
airear los trapos sucios en familia.
Max Aub es, sí, uno de
esos seres cordiales,
el sentido del [inaudible] del
corazón, y lo es Juan Ramón Jiménez.
He tenido la suerte, he
tenido la enorme suerte,
como ese átomo que empuja el viento,
en algún momento de haber llegado,
a un espacio, a un tiempo
preciso, en una historia concreta.
Y esa suerte, naturalmente,
como dice un grandísimo amigo
mío que hoy tiene en Barcelona la
fiorera [fonético] de 102 años,
la cual va dedicado el
capítulo sexto de este libro,
Manuel Velía [fonético],
que estuvo en el campo de
concentración del [inaudible],
que estuvo en los campos de
concentración de Franco en la línea
de la Concepción,
ese pueblo tocado por
la droga, el desempleo,
por su cercanía a esa diáspora,
la cual nos ha hablado Germán,
que estuvo en el campo
de Boloñi [fonético],
de los restos de la
civilización grecorromana,
fenicio-grecorromana-mediterránea,
los contempla,
allí hubo un grupo de
andrajosos, piojosos,
que se les comía el hambre.
Allí estuvo un joven de
20 años, como este hombre,
que sobrevivió a todo aquello,
y como digo, en los años 50-60,
bailó en algún antro de Madrid, nada
más y nada menos, con Ava Gardner,
[risas], y que no se jacta de ello.
Esa es la suerte, que tiene la
[inaudible] éste que les estaba
hablando, la suerte de
haber tenido, y ahí,
la cordialidad que en este
momento sirven para mí [fonético],
de haber tenido un padre y una
madre, como todos vosotros,
en particular, en este
caso, un padre,
verdaderamente al igual
que mi madre --
pero en este sentido lo que me ha
llevado a escribir este libro --
verdaderamente excepcional.
Y me lo recordaba hace unos días,
uno de sus discípulos, todavía,
vivo, un padre derrotado por
la Guerra Civil, un padre que,
al cual va en parte
dedicado este libro,
que de todas formas contaba
que iba al frente de batalla,
tomando el tranvía que
terminaba en la puerta de Toledo,
y a través de las trincheras de los
Carabancheles como milicianos de la
cultura, intentaba que
aquella república --
que otros, por otro lado,
asesinaban en Barcelona, haciendo
revoluciones y gritando contra la
burguesía conspiratoria, mientras el
fascismo empujaba en las puertas de
Madrid durante tres años.
Allí, el átomo que fue mi padre,
sobrevivió aquella matanza,
y sobrevivió a lo oprobio
de aquella matanza,
sobrevivió al terrible destino,
de verse entre los perdedores,
pero nunca perder la decencia y
de tener que abandonar aquel gran
proyecto que parece que un
abuelo mío, aquel, su padre,
había iniciado en aquellos años
de principios del siglo XX de las
Españas, una escuela madrilense
de estudios superiores,
cita en la calle de la luna 29,
donde los grandes maestros de la
época de restauración que dieron
paso a la época republicana,
venían a enseñar derecho y
muchísimas otras cosas a los futuros
egresados de la llamada Universidad
Central de la calle San Bernardo.
Este átomo que aquí os
habla, tuvo esa suerte.
Ese átomo cayó en ese punto
del tiempo y el espacio.
Y ese Naharro-Mora
-- decía Manuel Gala,
uno de sus directos discípulos,
se encontró con el espacio de
una economía política en Ciernes
[fonético] que había
iniciado, Flores de Lemus,
el padre de la economía
política española contemporánea,
se encontró sólo con otros pocos
discípulos y buscaron reconstruir de
alguna forma, una ciencia económica
en España que pudiera llamarse así.
Y recordó Gala, que en algún momento
en un congreso de economistas
mundiales donde habían acudido
diferentes premios nobeles,
alguien levantó una copa en honor
de aquel Naharro-Mora y dijo --
la economía española ha sobrevivido
gracias al hecho de que existieron
Naharro-Moras que entendieron que el
futuro de ese ciencia se encontraba
en un grupo de discípulos a los
cuales había que darles una salida
-- Y eso es lo que
fue en aquel sentido,
aquella España difícil en la que yo
nací, aquellos tranvías acinados,
en los cuales yo veía
a las gentes, muy niño,
cuando uno empieza a tener
esa conciencia de la vida,
tristemente agarrados,
aquellos metros macilentos,
aquellos asientos donde ponía
"reservado para mutilados
de guerra",
yo le preguntaba a mi madre,
y mi madre me mandaba
inmediatamente a callar.
Eso le conforma a uno,
en algún sentido.
Y sí tuve la suerte, ese
átomo tuvo la suerte,
de que aquel Naharro-Mora
hizo con su hijo,
lo que había hecho
con sus discípulos,
echarlo de aquel país de
alambradas y cárceles.
Y nunca, jamás, a penas hablarme de
lo que había significado aquel país
de alambradas y cárceles --
porque en ese sentido, efectivamente
es la moral como política la
que guiaba.
Y entonces todo se dio solo, porque
yo llegué al símbolo de este país,
a estas universidades increíbles,
con maestros increíbles,
que habían sido formados por
aquellos republicanos del exilio
de 1939.
Porque yo fui un átomo que salió
del conocimiento de Américo Castro a
través de [inaudible] y Samuel
[inaudible], dos hispanistas,
de tal altura, de tal
conocimiento, de tal generosidad.
O de Gonzalo Sobejano, que había
venido a los Estados Unidos a través
de la línea de Dámaso Alonso, a
través de la filología alemana.
O de Germán Guyol [fonético] que
había aprendido el camino que le
había enseñado su propio
padre Ricardo Guyol.
Todo eso era la universidad
estadounidense donde yo me formé.
Si en algo yo he podido escribir
este libro es porque tuve aquellos
ejemplos, porque tuve aquella
capacidad de reunir, además,
las lecturas que me fueron marcando,
y los átomos con los cuales
yo me fui encontrando,
el legado de Juan Ramón Jiménez.
Yo tuve la suerte de entrar
en un archivo en Puerto Rico,
donde estaban los manuscritos del
poeta y de todos sus contactos y
luego tuve la suerte de llegar al
universo de Max Aub, entre otros.
Bueno, no puedo contestar a todo lo
que habéis dicho de nuevo con tanta
generosidad, con tanto
conocimiento, y verdaderamente --
me siento, extremadamente
-- lo puedo decir, halagado,
por lo que se hizo presente
absolutamente, la dinámica,
el dinamismo que tú nos has
mostrado en estas imágenes,
en estas historias que están
ocurriendo ahora y que [inaudible].
Y Sebastián, ¿no?
Y yo creo que tiene tres o cuatro
Sebastianes, por ahí, ¿no?,
y los va sacando como Max Aub,
uno por semana o por mes,
etcétera, habéis dicho.
Bueno, simplemente, recordar que
efectivamente, sí, [inaudible].
[ Risas ]
Es barroquismo, no es barroco.
Y no me podría conformar conmigo
mismo, porque eso sí, también,
me lo enseñaron esos maestros,
a desconfiar, y a proseguir.
Y creo que si hay, unos, doctoras
y doctores egresados de mi mano,
y doctorandas en ciernes [fonético],
creo que, os he intentado legar,
y me habéis devuelto
esa generosidad.
Y eso naturalmente, pues, a
cualquier, a cualquier maestro,
si uno puede llamarse,
solamente le puede congratular.
Sí es un love story, y
como todos los love story,
pues tiene momentos en donde el
amor es complejo, donde hay peleas,
y efectivamente, duele, escribir
duele, escribir es difícil,
pensar algo que pueda llegar a la
escritura es aún más complicado y
atreverse hacerlo, creo
que ya, como digo, ¿no?,
desborda nuestra generosidad.
Tengo un defecto, efectivamente,
¿no?, no me contengo, pero bueno,
perdidos al río, ¿no?,
mientras haya ríos.
Tengo que confesaros que este
libro en muchos momentos --
se ha ajustado mientras este átomo
pedaleaba por las carreteras del
mundo, sigo siendo
un ávido ciclista,
y creo que debe homenajear a los
que los franceses llaman [hablando
francés], y ha mantenido con ciertos
ánimos, y ha sido en esos momentos,
a veces, en los cuales alguna
pequeña idea me ha surgido y ha ido
a ese libro.
Lo que pasa es que pedaleo
demasiado, entonces, por eso --
eso explica, ¿no?, la
enormidad de las páginas.
¿Y que más deciros?
Efectivamente, yo creo que un
libro que no guste a la mayoría,
por lo menos tiene con él la
esperanza de que a lo mejor,
en este tiempo, donde como sabemos
estamos dominados por los 140
caracteres, a lo mejor alguien se
inclina a interesarse por lo que
puede ser un libelo o una postura
excéntrica, etcétera, etcétera.
Espero no infectar a nadie
con el virus, efectivamente.
Y desde luego, espero seguir,
tener la oportunidad de seguir
pensando y seguir escribiendo
algunas cosas.
>> [Inaudible] un hueco [inaudible]
quizás abrir un poco el foro para
hacer alguna pregunta, pedirle por
favor a Germán y Sebastián si se
dejaron algo en el tintero
que no han mencionado,
si ustedes quieren preguntar algo
sobre algún aspecto específico,
me parece que eso sería el buen uso
de nuestros diez minutos que tenemos
antes de ser desalojados.
>> ¿Preguntas?
>> Sebastián Faber: Una cosa
que me surgió a propósito de la
presentación de Germán, yo terminé
preguntado ¿qué podemos hacer para
que el espíritu de
este libro cuele?,
y creo que tú indicaste el
camino, ¿no?, con las imágenes,
por ejemplo, ¿no?, las imágenes
son tan poderosas como tú indicas,
¿no?, en [inaudible] capítulos
sobre Centelles, por ejemplo,
y fotos yuxtapuestas son
muy poderosas, ¿no?,
como forma de traducir, de
mediar tu libro a un público,
que puede ser un público
de instituto,
no tiene que ser público
universitario ni siquiera, ¿no?,
entonces, ahí está, yo creo.
>> Sí, o sea, creo que allí hay
un potencial para hacer memes,
¿no?, [risas].
>> ¿Alguna pregunta?
>> Naharro, ¿estás contento con
el cómo presentaron tu libro?
¿Te parece que dejaron algo fuera
que tú crees que es importante,
algo que no vieron, algo que no -- ?
>> José María Naharro-Calderón:
Bueno, de nuevo,
lo que quiere decir,
es la generosidad con que ambos han
tratado lo que han leído, es decir,
que hayan llegado al final
vivos, ¿no?, [risas].
Creo que hay una multiplicidad de
elementos que ellos han destacado,
de los cuales podemos seguir sacando
punta, como digo, esto, por un lado,
creo que lo que Sebastián ha hecho
es situar efectivamente esto en un
tiempo y un espacio, desde
una tradición, un presente,
y tú has empezado a mirar desde ese
presente hacia lo que puede ser ese
futuro, lo que estás,
en este sentido planteando
desde tu trabajo, ¿no?
Bueno, quizás, una de las cosas de
las cuales yo creo que me siento --
más agradecido, de
nuevo, en este libro,
es en el poquísimo
conocimiento que tengo,
es el elemento de lomo economicus
[fonético] que hay en él,
en el que en general, las personas
que nos dedicamos a los estudios
culturales, etcétera,
tenemos ciertas dificultades porque
evidentemente la ciencia económica
es ciencia, ciencia social.
Yo tuve algunos conocimientos,
no desde luego por ese
lado de Naharro-Mora,
que nunca me habló de
economía, ojalá, ¿no?,
pero sí tuve algún interés y en
algún momento pensé que ese era mi
camino intelectual, ¿no?
Bueno, vivimos en un mundo,
a pesar de que estemos rodeados
aquí de libros de humanismo,
vivimos en un mundo de intereses, de
intereses económicos, de mercados,
¿no?, y dentro de este
totum revolutum en el cual,
a pesar de todo, todos aquí somos
unos privilegiados pertenecemos a
las primeras universidades del
mundo, etcétera, etcétera, etcétera.
Frente a estos seres,
¿no?, estas fotos,
que me recuerda esa foto de
Aluche, me recuerda a Ática 1971,
en el momento donde, creo, hay
este enorme motín y un motín,
ya no proyectado, a través de lo
que son los medios de comunicación,
aquel momento, la televisión,
casi de una forma continua, ¿no?,
etcétera, etcétera,
adelantándose a este presente, ¿no?
Bueno, el hecho de que todos
nuestros deseos, efectivamente,
toda esta justicia que rodeó a los
republicanos de las Españas, ¿no?,
que se fueron gestando en los años
30, que en España se vio, ¿no?,
el extraordinario libro
de David Jorge, ¿no?,
esa sociedad de naciones donde el
orden internacional se colapsa,
donde el último intento, ¿no?,
de alguna forma de una paz
universal, el intento kantiano,
y esto está en España,
y ahí está, como digo,
esta conexión de la cual
hablaba, ahí está Jiménez de Asúa,
es el que está en esa academia
de mi abuelo, etcétera, ¿no?,
y que el año te ve y dice
-- bueno señores, yo me voy,
yo me voy de aquí, yo
me voy a Argentina,
yo rehúso cobrar un solo duro del
erario republicano porque hay 500
mil personas en campos de
concentración y yo tengo una ética
-- Esa, donde efectivamente hoy
estos movimientos de indignados,
de 15M, [inaudible], etcétera,
están dando ese tipo de
ejemplos, ¿no?, en ese sentido.
Ese traslado moral,
¿no?, del hecho de que,
aunque vivamos rodeado de un arco,
¿no?, parece absolutamente, ¿no?,
[inaudible] de un capital
depredador, ¿no?
Amoral, de ciertos ejemplos,
mantienen cierta esperanza viva.
Y eso creo que efectivamente,
ese legado está, ese legado está,
y aunque naturalmente
yo puedo señalar,
y puedo efectivamente contradecir, y
puedo indicar que a lo mejor, bueno,
las cosas no fueron así, pero --
, ¿no?, y que nuestra labor
educativa, nuestro trabajo,
todavía tiene un sentido en la
tradición de Malarmé [fonético],
¿no?, de darle sentido a las
palabras de la tribu, todavía,
a pesar de que esa puede ser una
posición neo ortegiana [fonético]
muy conservadora.
Recordar, que si somos minoría
en el sentido de Ortega,
es porque Ortega pide que la
minoría se exija a sí misma,
y creo que todos nosotros
lo hacemos,
y que a través de esa exigencia,
a lo mejor todavía mantenemos
ese cardón sanitarius [fonético]
necesario de la ética.
Yo creo que ese es el legado de esos
extraordinarios incunables que nos
han traído aquí la Biblioteca del
Congreso y con los cuales todos,
de nuevo, cuando llevamos nuestra
mano y abrimos esas páginas,
nos reencontramos con ese átomo
moral que al fin y al cabo esperamos
que somos todos nosotros.
>> Vale, yo seré la
mala de la película,
y tengo que parar el
desborde aquí, [risas].
Muchas gracias a los tres ¿no?
Por este evento, tengo que
disculparme a ustedes vinieron a una
presentación de libro y al final
fue una conferencia, ¿no?,
que hemos aprendido cosas
nuevas, fue impresionante,
un repaso histórico impresionante,
así que un millón de gracias.
Esto no termina aquí, podemos seguir
dialogando con José María y con los
dos presentadores, vamos a Sonoma,
que está aquí aproximadamente a una
cuadra y media, al segundo piso,
y ahí disfrutaremos
de una happy hour.
Gracias otra vez por estar
aquí, y vamos, por favor,
si pueden mirar los afiches y
los incunables en cinco minutos y
tenemos que salir antes
de la 5 definitivamente.
Gracias otra vez a la
Biblioteca del Congreso por esto.
[ Aplausos ]
>> José María Naharro-Calderón:
Y una pequeña coda [fonético]
publicitaria, si puedo, ¿no?,
el día 26 de octubre
estáis todos convocados,
un pequeño coloquio que vamos a
tener a las 2 de la tarde en la
Universidad de Maryland en St.
Mary's Hall [fonético] titulado
"Sights and sounds
and USA landscapes",
entre ellos va a participar,
aquí mi colega Carmen
Benito-Vessels,
con un libro que pronto vamos a
presentar en este mismo espacio,
y a las 6:45 de la tarde,
en el edificio de la oficina
cultural de la Embajada de España en
la Calle 16, tenemos en esa conexión
atómica con Juan Ramón Jiménez,
entre otros, ¿no?,
nuestro Premio Nobel,
en el centenario de la
publicación de su diario
"Un poeta recién casado",
un concierto extraído
de los trabajos,
de los poemas de Juan Ramón
Jiménez en la época americana,
tanto del 17 como del exilio,
que ha llevado música del compositor
español Carlos José Martínez y que
va a interpretar, y de ahí
la continuidad moral y ética,
mi propia hija, la soprano
Anaís Naharro-Murph.
Todos invitados a ese momento donde
vamos a recordar a Juan Ramón y
entre otras cosas, a su relación
con esa excelente figura que fue
Andy Wallace.
Perdonar la coda publicitaria,
pero ya que os tengo aquí, ¿no?,
dos por uno, y ahora el happy hour.
[ Aplausos ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov